واحد اكبر من ابي يغتصب
روستها اي ديانه ترضاها
اي قبيله ترضاها
[موسيقى]
كنت اعتقد انه راح يعاقبوني طبعا
انا ايدي ومن رجليني
فاغتصبني يعني ايش ذنبي يعني انا انا
ما الي ذنبي يعني بهذا الشيء
[موسيقى]
رجعونا
للموصل
بالموصل كمان امي اغتصبت من قبل شخص اسمه
براء
هو من الموصل مهمات
كان عمره 20 سنه اغتصب ماما
[موسيقى]
يمكن باعجوبه نجود
كانوا حاطين مع الاموات
انه
حتى انا استغرب انه كيف انه نجوت من هذاك
اربع صواريخ وقعوا البنايه كلها وقعت بس
الحمد لله رجعت للحياه
ضليت 3 اشهر بالمستشفى
[موسيقى]
اخذوا ابي واخوي واخذونا نحنا النسوان
والبنات وفرقوا الصغير عن الكبير كل واحد
راح بمكان
بعد فتره
مره ثانيه جمعونا بالمدرسه
وقالوا راح نطلعكم بس للاسف اخذوا الرجال
كلهم قتلوهم
[موسيقى]